When I was born, doctors said I had a condition that affected every part of me,
from my body to my brain.
When you're like me, people don't always give you a chance.
They put me in a different school.
They put me in a different team.
They talked to me in a different way...
...but I never wanted to be treated any differently.
I wanted to be independent, so I learned to drive.
I love sports, so I took part in any way I could.
When my condition became so bad, I lost feeling in my legs.
I learned to walk again.
And when I wanted to work, I got a job.
It's a struggle every day...
...but I still get up because work makes me feel that I'm reaching my goals.
I'm part of a team.
And I get to give back to my family.
My whole life people have been telling me I have a learning disability.
I guess they're right because I have never learned how to give up.